the agenda is set I'm Brent Gough in
Berlin it's time to talk Germany the
export giant has this success story
become a handicap for the rest of Europe
the US military in Germany is there a
secret war being waged illegally and the
president of Camelot shot and killed 50
years later
what does JFK mean to the world well
welcome to the show everyone I have
invited three people today to talk argue
and pry apart these headlines my first
guest is our own eyewitness to the end
of Camelot I'm happy to welcome back to
the show Irwin Collier he is an
economics professor and T is the chair
at the JFK Institute at the Free
University here in Berlin oh it's good
to have you back on the show my second
guest says he has uncovered evidence
that the United States is probably
conducting its global war on terror from
Germany with Berlin's permission I'm
happy to welcome to the show John Gertz
he is an investigative journalist and he
is co-author of the book and the TV
series secret Wars which is airing right
now and Jeremy John good to have you on
the show and my next guest says yes
Germany's trade surplus is unfair to the
rest of Europe I'm happy to welcome
stormy Milner she's an economist with
the German Institute for International
and security affairs let me start by
asking all of you start though with you
story do you believe the criticism some
would say the hype that's out there
right now is Germany hurting the rest of
Europe by selling so many goods abroad I
actually don't I think the global
macroeconomic imbalances or
macroeconomic imbalances in general can
become a problem
as we have seen before the last
financial and economic crisis which was
caused in part by macroeconomic
imbalances but we have to look very
carefully at what the causes of these
imbalances
and I think that a multitude of
different factors explain why Germany
has such a large current account surplus
we're gonna get to those factors just
say let me pull the other gentleman in
here John what do you think I mean are
we hearing sincere criticism or is this
a lot of hype whether there's hype I
mean I really can't say I mean I just I
see living in Berlin some of the effects
of the crisis because you see a lot of
capital coming in from other countries
and investing in the real estate market
that's the kind of thing that that I've
noticed but whether that's hyper not is
I'm interested here what you say well
it's actually you know very serious
people having a lot of experience in
financial crisis like the IMF have been
quite clear that continued net export
surpluses and we have to emphasize net
can in fact be a problem and for the
eurozone I think they are a problem ok
mister me I remember you said earlier
that you blame the design of the
European Union for for Germany's export
muscle are you telling us that Germany
is a victim of one of its most prized
creation no but I think there are some
some issues with regard to the eurozone
and its mechanisms which prevent that
there is a natural adjustment mechanism
I mean the eurozone is not an optimal
currency area where you could through
either labor mobility or price
flexibility adjust to a symmetric shocks
we have neither we don't have for labor
mobility nor price price flexibility
other regions can't compensate like the
United States really do have more of an
adjuster may take advantage
you just finish my thought so what you
actually need is you do need a more of a
fiscal Union where you do have another
adjustment mechanism you don't have the
adjustment mechanism of exchange rates
anymore so you need to adjust through
more fiscal measures we're going to come
back the fiscal Union in just a second a
lot of people saying around the world
that Germany is a creeping threat for
the global economy now that is the
message that we're getting from
Washington and now Brussels the European
Commission has even launched an
investigation into Germany's large
current account surpluses saying Germany
sells too much abroad and not enough at
home too much export muscle that elbows
out southern European economies trying
to compete their way out of the eurozone
crisis well the government here in
Berlin says its export dominance is the
result of two decades of painful
economic reforms here so how much of
this beating up on the champion is sound
economics and I'm wondering how much of
it is just sour grapes politics Germany
has long taken pride in its status as
one of the world's leading export
nations but despite the country's
economic might domestic demand remains
relatively weak Germany is beginning to
come under fire for importing far less
than it exports the US Treasury recently
accused Berlin of hurting the global
economy and holding back European growth
now the EU has decided to investigate
high surplus does not necessarily mean
that there is an imbalance but we do
need to examine this further and
understand whether the high surplus in
Germany is something that is affecting
the functioning of European economy as a
whole but is this criticism really fair
isn't it Germany's export-driven economy
that has been keeping the rest of Europe
afloat in the debt crisis that is an
argument isn't it for me that if you
didn't have Germany doing so well you
wouldn't have anyone to write the
checkbook for the bailout of the rest of
the eurozone well in part that is true
but on the other hand there is also
truth and what
just heard that the saving grade in
Germany is relatively high domestic
consumption is comparatively low and
there could actually be done more with
regard to internal investment as well as
domestic domestic spending which also
would have a push for growth in the
other European Member State and that is
getting a lot a lot of currency right
now people just do not spend money in
Germany the way they could you've all
spent time outside of Germany in the
United States is there something that
needs to change about this economy that
makes people want to spend more money no
I don't think you have to change the
economy it's really an issue of economic
policy and it's also a labor market
policy just because we don't have the
full fiscal Union doesn't mean there
aren't things that could be done to help
get rid of some of these imbalances
within the euro zone for instance a
grand push for investment it doesn't all
have to be one big party of consumption
there is plenty to be done that would
actually improve the long-term
productivity of German workers here in
Germany and that's the guarantee not our
exporting what's the guarantee of our
high living standards is the high
productivity productivity is high though
oh it can be higher yeah I mean there
are actually lots of studies osed
studies to show that long-term growth
prospects are relatively dim for Germany
because we do have infrastructure
deficits big time as well as educational
deficits and that's where the spending
needs to do not consumptive spending but
invest of span okay so in other words we
need to see industry we need to see the
government write bigger checks before
infrastructure right but what about the
consumer here in all of this though are
you telling me stormy that the German
consumer is spending enough no no the
common consumer in first of all we have
an aging population and then a lot of
money now but that usually leads to more
more saving and the second factor is
that Germans are a little insecure about
the future and looking at neighbor can't
you can kind of understand this why you
would rather save instead of consume
more and that is difficult to address
for the government to really change
consumer behavior that's a tricky issue
you know you're bringing up a couple of
interesting points there cultural
barriers cultural differences in Europe
you know your what we're asking people
we're asking Spaniards Italians and
Greeks to mind the shop the same way a
German would or a Dutchman would is that
realistic actually I'd like to phrase it
a little bit differently it's for the
imbalances it's expected that the
periphery companies all bite a bullet
take this austerity hit and all that is
being asked of Germany right now is
actually why don't you spend more and
you don't have to spend money foolishly
you can there's plenty of infrastructure
projects to be done and if you look at
the comparative competitiveness
increases in German wages at this point
would help the adjustment so that the
bullets that have to be bitten in the
periphery won't be nearly as hard but
the government's not willing to do that
well the government doesn't get involved
in it that's a call to the trade unions
actually and not to the government and
do you think that the austerity demands
that they have in Eastern Europe that
they have of Eastern Europe is me of
southern European countries are actually
right is it is that actually the right
policy it's within a context of both
sides and imbalances making adjustments
it would be part of any long-term recipe
for getting the eurozone back into
balance the problem is it's being very
asymmetrical as though those countries
have to make the adjustment in terms of
austerity and that a little more in an
old sense of the word inflation in the
sense of more purchasing power chasing
goods in Germany would be something that
would actually make that adjustment
easier at the g20 or g20 countries
agreed that both both are surplus
countries need to adjust in the deficit
countries need to adjust by doing
structural adjustment mechanisms so it's
just fair that Germany also plays
you know but what keeps coming up all
the time even even in this criticism of
Germany I mean think about how absurd it
may sound to an outsider that Germany is
being criticized for doing something so
well I mean it sells goods machines all
over the world people want to buy these
items it's a winner it's a champion but
the problem it remains the eurozone and
that this currency union has bugs in it
that continue to raise their head so we
keep walking around in circles here it's
broken
no one's gonna fix it so are we going to
live with a broken system well I
certainly hope that the pain is going to
be big enough at one point that the
right reforms will take place inside the
European Union and the eurozone I mean
looking at storica you mentioned that
that's not happening I mean even Angela
Merkel she wants it and she has no
political capital right now with that
argument she can't get a pass you can't
get a push no one wants to talk about a
fiscal union well I mean to be honest
for the last few years the Merkel
government really did not for so much
for for stronger Europeanisation they'd
only kicked in a I mean pretty recently
so I think stronger push by the German
government for more for more you of and
sort of alessio of what would be the way
to go you can coordinate your fiscal
policies and that's far short of full
fiscal union always to demand kind of
the full monty when you know much less
than that can satisfy your customers the
real thing that we need is to coordinate
the fiscal policies and it's in these
imbalances it really requires greater
fiscal expansion on the part of the
Germans as a tightening in the periphery
it's just right now it's completely
asymmetric and it was rather asymmetric
when the currency union began we know
now that a lot of the numbers that we
were given we're not or lies all right
so we've been living with with you know
a patient that's sick from that from the
beginning
you know I keep coming back to the
question what will it take to bring some
type of symmetry to the eurozone so that
you don't have the argument Germany is
taking advantage of its privileged
position first of all you need to
explain better what the European Union
and the eurozone is about and I think
this has been not done for I mean to the
voter to the people for the last few
years the whole issue had been framed
like Germany is the victim here Germany
as has to bail out all the other
countries for their problems and for
their faults and it's not a surprise I
mean if you don't explain how much
Germany actually benefited from the euro
and the the European Union if you don't
explain that then you don't have the
support by the people and then the
government can date but don't you think
that's clear unemployment is low in
Europe people have a lot of money I mean
the Germans are not complaining right
now it's the southern Europeans it's a
big a lot of people in Germany and a lot
of the populist newspapers run this line
that you know we're bailing out the
whole you know all of Europe and Greece
and Spain and everyone just wants money
from us that's definitely a widely
believed thing I think when you cast
everything as a morality play there are
those who live within their means
they're good and they shouldn't be
punished and there's others who don't
live in their means somehow when you are
looking at the average voter Joe or Jane
six-pack you know they are not
responsible for fundamental
macroeconomic failures of their own
governments they are in the boat they
they have to bear the consequences it's
not the issue that German voters should
bear the consequences but what is being
asked is not that they inflicts
austerity policy on themselves what is
being asked is open up your checkbooks
start building your bridges yes what's
it why do you think politicians and even
the wise men in in Germany we can't get
them to come out and say this
the Germans are being asked to be the
paymaster in Europe right now but there
is no single there is no fiscal union
there's no harmonization of fiscal
policy of tax policy so
can you really ask the German taxpayer
to take up that responsibility and that
liability of something that he and she
has never signed up for well that's not
cried I mean Germany did and and the
consumer and the people as well did
benefit greatly from the European
program and first of all it's a
political project and it helped to
create pre peace and stability on this
continent that shouldn't be forgotten
and the second the second point is that
it's stable currency helps exports also
within the European Union tremendously
reduces insecurities reduces cost
transaction costs so so that the
consumer really has benefited from both
political as well as explained how it
okay to the Germans but the average
Greek Italian Spanish consumer and
they're not going to buy that argument
they're gonna they've seen incredible
cuts to all types of programs their
wages have been cut if they work for any
type of municipality if they work for
the government the social security
systems in all these countries has been
cut in Greece but as much as in some
places up to 80% they're gonna believe
that Germany has greatly benefited from
it okay yeah that's that's what they're
going to believe they're gonna believe
that they've suffered and and that's
another form of asymmetry no one feels
like they're in the same boat here well
you'll also notice when the crisis began
there was not a huge movement of
politicians say from the core so that
it's not just a question of Germany but
from the core to the periphery it was
much more delegations of the sub
secretary level are going in telling
people how to get their house in order
because it's a political project there
should have been a lot of core
politicians going out there trying to
also instill the hope we are in this
together there is a solidarity among
eurozone members this is not just bitter
medicine there are there are hopes and
this is what we're doing this sort of
communication didn't take place speaking
of us being in this too
other stormy these coalition talks right
now here in Germany looks like we're
going to have a grand coalition
government is that going to be the
government that's finally going to open
up the pocketbook and start spending on
infrastructure education research the
things that are needed in Germany if
you're looking at the coalition working
groups currently it really doesn't look
the way I mean the the cdu/csu have a
clear agenda and more spending is
definitely not on it it's rather with
using the the further reducing the depth
as well as keeping keeping a balanced
budget
okay so austerity is here to stay
alright the economy is not it's not what
has lawmakers here in Berlin talking
this week the parliament has begun
debating the NSA spying affair now we
still don't know what berlin plans to do
if anything to stop the u.s. from spying
on Germans on German soil and this week
a team of investigative journalists here
in Germany have begun presenting what
they claim is evidence that Washington
is conducting a secret war against
terror with something like a command
center right here in Germany oh if true
that would be a violation of German law
international law but the German
government doesn't seem too alarmed so
far a team of journalists in Germany
have been investigating allegations of
cooperation between the US military and
the German government their presence at
facilities such as the CIA logistics
center in Frankfurt have invited
interests from German police and their
findings are explosive the journalists
said that the u.s. is using German bases
to coordinate its war on terror in
Africa the stationing of US troops in
Germany reportedly costs taxpayers here
around a hundred million euros a year so
what exactly is the u.s. military doing
on German soil and is it legitimate
one of the reporters that you know we
saw there you've been conducting this
investigation
what is the headline coming out of this
what do are we to understand a secret
war in Germany what does that mean well
the surprising thing about the research
is that we found that the drone strikes
that the United States was carrying out
in Somalia and have been a series of
drone strikes in the last few years are
have a great deal to do with Germany and
far more than we ever imagined the
commandos the the the central military
command for all African military
operations is not in Africa surprisingly
it's actually in Stuttgart and it came
to Germany after 12 African countries
refused to take it so every drone strike
that happens in Somalia does have its
you know or origin in Germany the other
thing that was interesting are you
saying that those attacks though are
being steered and yep commanded and well
the command the decision to do the to do
the drone strike or any military
operation in Africa and there's been a
lot of there's an increase of
anti-terrorism activity by the American
military in Africa all gets decided in
took our data the actual the actual
soldier or pilot who's controlling that
drone are they sitting in Germany well
the fascinating thing about a drone is
that we have kind of this notion of
world war one where there's there's you
know to kind of armies sitting across
from each other about you know 200 yards
from each other and it's actually if you
look at the act a Predator drone is a
system and you have the pilot based in
Nevada or you know somewhere in the
southwest of the United States you have
the drone and Djibouti but you have the
infrastructure connecting those two
things as well as targeting information
coming out of Germany
and as your research and your
investigation shown that this is being
done without the German government's
permission it would be a huge mistake
for anyone to think that this stuff is
happening without the absolute agreement
of the Jim
government anyone who's claiming that
doesn't understand that the German
government is intimately involved in
this I mean there are there are German
military advisers and liaison officers
at AFRICOM at Ramstein where the where
the drone strikes are being tracked
there's also a great German military
presence this is not being done against
the wishes of the German government it's
being done with the German government so
what's the problem the problem is is
that the German government in general
has not leveled with the population
about their activities so for example
when Somali refugees asylum seekers in
Germany get kind of pumped for
information that ends up in the
targeting system of the United States
that's kept secret I mean Germany is not
being honest with its puppets if the
German government is not being honest
with its population about its role and
for the most part it's doing this
without telling the parliament okay I
mean there's a few different things but
the public knows and and maybe what a
parliamentary inquiry
our committee would know Bob Woodward in
the United States has said that there is
a secret government in the United States
right now that is directing things like
the NSA what I'm hearing here is that
you're saying there may be something
similar in Germany if Germany itself is
not an arm of that secret government
well I mean the argument that we're
making is that it's a mistake to think
that the security systems of the United
States and Germany are separate things
and we have this kind of historical
notion that there's two DS two different
countries in two different military
security apparatus but it's actually
they're so intertwined and so much a
part of each other it's very hard to
separate it so when you have that kind
of development in the United States it
carries over here because Germany is a
significant platform on every level for
the American military as well as of
course for the CIA as well and and and
is in the intelligence services the u.s.
embassy here has responded to your
investigation and they've called the
secret war Germany and the role of
America is full of half-truths
speculation and innuendo
the embassy seems to think that what you
were telling the German public is not
true and what the German government has
been saying is the truth so someone's
lying yeah I mean the thing is just that
that the truth lies when you get
specific right and the question is is
that of course the AFRICOM has told us
that all military operations are being
commanded out of Stuttgart there's not
actually no debate about that I mean so
when you get specific and you talk about
our Somali refugees being questioned and
does the information show up in the
targeting system that's also something
that's actually under available and does
Rammstein used to track flights and is
there a CIA logistics center in
Frankfort that was used for a variety of
operations in the Bush era um just
really no debate about that I don't know
you think all of this information that
what you're finding out does all of this
information need to be part of public
discourse does the average German need
to be privy to all of these decisions
that are being made between the Secret
Service of the United States the VND in
Germany I mean I think it's a
fundamental question of you know
democracy I mean do you want an informed
population to be involved and to know
but how much that's my question how much
is enough I mean you have intelligence
committees in Parliament
they're there to know everything but the
public never knows everything they know
all right you had something the very
beginning that you said it was secret
and illegal and I guess the secret I've
have less trouble with but the illegal
so I'd like to hear more about what are
the particular illegal aspects of the
cooperation yeah we don't we don't
necessarily claim illegal in any of the
things that we're doing there's
something that they said but there is an
argument an obvious argument and that is
is that there's a german constitutional
clause that says that you cannot wage
aggressive war out of german territory
territory so that means when americans
are waging that's aggressive war fun
german territory when americans are
doing it the question is is that a
violation of kind of the you know one of
the deepest parts of the german
understanding of themselves but wouldn't
it be a vile
if the drone if the if the pilot of that
drone is sitting in Stuttgart then I
think most people would say you have a
violation of German law there German
soil is being used to conduct aggressive
warlike maneuvers depends on how you
define war and secondly what you use the
drones for because I mean drones can be
used for surveillance or that can be
used for for targeted killing killings
and if I'm not mistaken then the German
government has supported the
surveillance aspect of drones and
opposed the killings or the targeted
killings food drones and if they were
used for the letter than I think then it
is clearly in this leading of the public
if they allow something else and saying
well whose misleading the POTUS I mean
John is saying here that that the
Parliament doesn't know it does the
government is the government not sharing
information with this Angela Merkel is
her cabinet the people closer to her are
they keeping secrets that should be
shared with Parliament well I mean one
of the things that was interesting was
when Africa whether the decision was
made to have the AFRICOM command centre
interested guard and not in an African
country they went to the foreign
ministry and the Defense Ministry here
and asked could we please have it here
and it was they wanted the US wanted to
announce it in Bush's state of the
nation speech in 2007 I believe or 2006
and the German said yes please it's okay
you can have Africa I'm here but please
don't mention it in a speech it would
quote unleash an unnecessary public
discussion and so there's a long
tradition in Germany of around security
issues of kind of the government feeling
that the population which has always
been very pacifist in its inclinations
right that they're not sophisticated
enough to understand the deep serious
security threats affecting Germany and
that's why we'd rather decide these
things on a higher level without the
population being above it but that's it
that's a huge indictment to make though
to say that the public cannot take the
truth
well I mean it's been that way I mean
it's the creation of the Bundeswehr with
joining NATO in 1950 or whenever it was
I mean who they I mean since the the the
nuclear missiles in in 1982 I mean
there's always been a huge pacifistic
consensus in the German population and
there's always been the German
government which is trying to basically
fight against that curious how you see
my question here's what do you think is
in the German interest of the
policymakers I'm trying to figure out
given the likelihood something like this
can unwind oh yeah what is your sense
yeah who is gaining within the German
policy establishment to be cooperative
on this particular point or is it just
once you say yes once you're hooked
forever oh I mean again I really believe
that the security systems are so
intertwined it's very difficult for
Germany to get out of anything and so
when the United States starts to do
drone attacks in Somalia it's very hard
to pull the you know pull the break I
mean it's no there's almost no way to
get out of it and so I mean one of the
things that was also fascinating it's
also there that's an incredible
statement to make though I mean imagine
someone in France or someone in the u.s.
saying a foreign government is working
on our soil and doing things that we
can't even check on that's and no one
would accept that first of all well
what's fascinating we've happened that
there's actually no institution in
German American relations where there's
a yearly monthly weekly report about
what the American military does in
Germany so actually there's actually no
accountability well there's actually
told to us by the foreign ministry yeah
but isn't that the duty of the
intelligence services of Germany I mean
that's what they're here for is to know
what's going on in Germany well whenever
we've been to background meetings with
intelligence services here that's always
been that we do not spy on our allies
all right that's always been what do you
mean you're not spying if you're working
in your country well we don't do counter
espionage against our own
and that may be changing I mean that
really they'd be a different thing right
now do you think you know these here
these debates going on in Parliament
right now do you think there needs to be
a greater call for German the the
Parliament as well as the intelligence
agencies that they should have to come
before a committee and explain what
they've been doing for the last 10 years
well there certainly will be a
parliamentary investigation into the NSA
allegations it's also likely that much
of the stuff that we've been covering
will get included in that parliamentary
investigation it should start in March
is what I understand is when what it'll
begin ok very briefly before we move on
I have heard some people comparing you
and your colleagues on this team a
German version of Edward Snowden well I
mean Snowden is I mean it would be a
great honor to be compared with Edward
Snowden
I mean Snowden was able though to
provide an amazing amount of information
to people all around the world about
what the United States is doing
borrowing this project without him right
we were certainly helped by a lot of the
material that he was able to get out all
right all right let's move on this week
we're gonna stay with the United States
the US and much of the world will
remember the 50th anniversary of the
assassination of President John F
Kennedy now almost everyone in my
parents generation can tell you where
they were when they heard that JFK had
been shot his death more than any other
event marked the end of America's
post-war crescendo as a superpower the
end of Camelot the fairy tale well there
are now two other generations that know
only the conspiracy theories the movies
the documentaries and the feeling that
we still don't have closure on that
horrific event well today we asked is it
time to put the past in the past and
what does jf Skate legacy mean now and
not what your country can do for you ask
what you can do for your country
handsome and charismatic John F Kennedy
was seen in his lifetime as a new type
of president who revitalized America
after the conformist 1950s in Germany
JFK is best remembered for his speech in
West Berlin which gave hope to the
people of the divided city but over the
years perceptions have shifted as more
details about his private life and
political life emerged was JFK really
more image than reality
what is his legacy now 50 years after
his assassination and how much of what
Kennedy symbolized lives on today all of
them let me pick up on what we just
talked about what would a JFK do in this
situation with Europe looking at the
United States now as an ally that can't
be trusted what I mean can you imagine
in many ways what happened when the
Berlin Wall went up that you know a gun
bar has said it many times that suddenly
German policymakers realized that when
push comes to shove niceties about
Berlin take second the backseat to
international global stability and
avoiding nuclear confrontation that the
United States will act in ways that are
perhaps not directly pushing German
interests that was one of the lessons
why the austere politique came as a
reaction out of this experience oh it's
not just enough to play on a successful
team it also requires having an active
sort of proactive policy with respect to
the East it sound like you're saying
he'd be doing exactly what Obama is
doing today he'd be certainly doing
trying to straighten things up a lot of
bad has happened he was just fortunate
that his predecessor Dwight the
Eisenhower did not leave
as much to clean up as Obama's
predecessor what when we talk about a
legacy of JFK what are we talking about
now in the 21st century does he mean
anything now to the US and the world I
think it's long enough ago for us to
start seeing how symbols matter more the
symbol of JFK the fact that his
assassination took place that this was a
shared shock to the world to the United
States and then it's like a bookend as
you said to the period that preceded and
what came after there was with the
Vietnam War with the civil rights
revolution we also have the beginning of
feminism many things were happening
the real break I think in that
self-confidence comes with sort of the
breakdown of Bretton Woods you have the
OPEC crisis in the 70s but everything
started everything kind of started to
get messy right after he died right well
that's what this was any we were talking
about spying on each other that's the
the sense of a book and people remember
yeah somehow before that life seems so
simple and predictable and afterwards
things started to unwind I mean I wonder
if we sugarcoat Camelot when we remember
because I mean the first thing you
always hear is people say oh he was such
a handsome man you know they're thinking
about things that they liked that's one
thing and the other thing I want to ask
all three of you is what about the
conspiracy theories most people will
tell you today they do not know who was
responsible for JFK's death we're still
talking about that today
his is that his legacy is that we don't
know why he died I think the fact that
when you ask people I ask my students
this morning
JFK what's the first thing that comes in
your mind the the mode most people said
the assassination that somehow that is
what they they don't think of the Cuban
Missile Crisis they don't think
they we're in Berlin they didn't even
say ich bin ein Berliner it was only
when I asked him about that this oh yeah
that's right he said that to the
assassination is that symbolic moment
that everyone has conspiracy theories
are exactly kind of and what you're
saying that fits in exactly with this
pattern this idea that the United States
was this beautiful peaceful nation that
was kind to the world and you know that
that Kennedy gets shocked and everything
starts kind of falling apart and you
have the right and the left kind of
agreeing that there was this major
change afterwards and it's a very naive
notion of what the United States was
like before 1963 right and it's just
it's got nothing to do with reality I
mean Kennedy was the man you know who
permitted and in order the Bay of Pigs
invasion right but we're still dealing
with naivete aren't we I mean a lot of
people would say that you know the way
the reaction in Germany has been to do
this the NSA scandal shows a lot of
naivete that the reality of
relationships are just like marriages
you know you accept some thing some
things you don't but it's never neat and
clean
is it relationship has changed greatly
in compare I mean today we do have a
different relationship than in the 60s
or 70s we are not the natural first
order partner of the United States
anymore which is vital for anything done
internationally stability wise we are
one of many partners and I think that
the decision with whom to do what is
decided much more pragmatically today
and I think for many Germans the NSA
scandal it was kind of an wake-up call
and to kind of grasp this reality and
sometimes we were mentis eyes or idea I
idealize our relationship with the
United States and I think it's just it
hasn't been this for 20 years yeah I
mean JFK did deliver its benign
billionaire a speech here in Berlin I
mean the Germans always give a special
invitation to an American president
there is that special
relationship well it was a real
commitment and it helped stabilize a
situation that could have gotten out of
control and I think the fact that it was
a credible promise of solidarity clearly
also in the United States interest but
Germany was not in a position as a
divided country to do anything but hope
that things would turn out for the
better and in fact what happened as soon
as the Berlin Wall fell down you know
the first reaction of George Bush Senior
when told this was nothing subtle simply
that's great yeah but it is interesting
what you said that you asked your
students today and what they remember
his assassination and not that night and
Marilyn Monroe I mean there is that side
of him too he is probably the first the
first modern president where people did
talk about his private life we're
running out of time but the day he died
what happened the people responsible
will we ever have an answer it's been 50
years I mean a lot of files can be open
now a lot of files that were classified
after 30 years 25 years they can be open
is there an answer out there I suspect
there is an answer in files and it's
probably less exciting that people want
to see my own personal favorite is
simply we have a lot of people covering
their backsides and because of that
there's been an enormous amount of
information that has been hidden from
view and that ultimately historians do
track this stuff down it's they're like
journalists with a long time horizon
long deadline let me ask you - do you
think Germany will ever have this love
affair with an American president the
way it did with JFK is it possible I
think at the beginning of the Obama
administration to very much had I mean
high support weights you spoke before he
was elected he spoke ever see Obama's
biggest rally here was in Berlin and
there was
an enormous support for Obama but it's
been the drone strikes it's been the war
on terror that is that is really an NSA
scandal it's collapse to support the NSA
scanner we always come back there to
where we started all right that's gonna
wrap up this edition of agenda with
Brent Goff remember you can contact me
any time with your thoughts on the show
you can find me on Facebook and you can
tweet me at Brent goth TV email us you
see the address on your screen and if
you want to watch the show again go to
DWS website or watch us on YouTube I'm
Brent Goff in Berlin join me next time
when I set the agenda